[Music]
got a little surprise for you son no no
no no no dance oh you gotta be kidding
me yeah I am you're not getting a
Porsche
let me tell you something son a driver
don't pick the cars because the driver
it's a mystical bomb between man and
machine
[Music]
foreign
is totally classified
what is this
we're under attack
we're facing war against the
technological civilization for Superior
to our own
enemy can take any shame
they could be anywhere
it's a robot you know like super
Advanced robot it's probably Japanese
foreign
foreign
I want to talk to you about the college
thing okay
I'm not taking you with me
look at this place I feel smarter
already can you smell it yeah it smells
like 40 000 a year
hey beautiful meet you a long distance
relationship kid I got your webcam so we
can chat 24 7. sounds cute I can't wait
foreign
[Music]
mental meltdown in the middle of my
class I've seen symbols we've kept much
from you Sam this isn't my War I fear it
soon will be
what you're about to see is top secret
do not tell my mother any of these look
like the symbols you saw where did you
get these archaeologists found these
unexplained mockings and ancient ruins
all over the world they gotta mean
something like a message or like a map
foreign
watch what's in my mind
[Music]
fate rarely calls upon us at a moment of
our choosing
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
our entire space race of the 1960s was
in response to an event
if you breathe a word of what you've
seen here we'll do time for treason
foreign
humans know of our planet we were told
had been shared
you lied to us you've made a grave
mistake
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
you may lose your faith in us but never
in yourselves
from here the fight will be your own
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the greatest advance in modern
physics since the splitting of the atom
a rare medal molecularly unstable
it's what they're made of
[Music]
bring it up all the way
[Music]
dad you can't keep spending money on
junk I don't think it's a truck at all I
think we just found a Transformer
[Music]
let me ask you this once
where's Optimus Prime
after all we have done
humans are hunting us
but I fear we are all Targets now
what is that
who said you're here
[Music]
this is not war
it's human extinction
how many more of my kind must be
sacrificed and I have faith Prime maybe
not in Who We Are
and we can be
I'm not leaving my dad we
age a new Army
it started as a legend
one of the greatest of all
thousand years we've kept it hidden
to protect Earth
it was destined to arrive Optimus Prime
you destroyed your home do you seek
Redemption
money maker I do
[Music]
your daughter what would you say to her
brush your teeth work hard
to stay away from any boy in a band
especially a drummer
troubled time
without leaders chaos rains
Two Worlds
colliding
you're all that stand in its way
and now the greatest mission of them all
to turn the tide of human history
[Applause]
the imminent destruction of everything
we know and love begins
when all seems lost a few brave souls
[Music]
I save everything we've ever known
the operation's over we're not giving up
on Prime okay
[Music]
for my world to live
yours Must Die
[Music]
I'm Charlie Watson I'm 18. today
actually
is the Beetle for sale
happy birthday
[Music]
what are you
so you have no idea where he came from
no idea
[Applause]
wow here's the deal
people can be terrible about things they
don't understand
from now on only person you can show
yourself around is me
oh I'm good
now I'm good thanks
isn't found that war may find its way
sir anyone that can help you you have a
family
oh me
in an army
I've seen firsthand these things really
are
there is only one way to end this war
must protect Earth and its people take
it down
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
another stand down I'm not the one to
fear Pride
there is a Darkness coming
okay
it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving
way
and if you don't know
of all the threats
from both your past
and future you
've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know that you know
[Music]
thank you
[Music]